One last problem in
this section.
Let's see, problem number 16.
After the first term, each
term in a sequence is 3
greater than 1/3 the
preceding term.
So if I were to write that--
so if I were to say n of i
plus 1 is equal to the
preceding term
times 1/3 plus 3.
And all I'm saying is, if
I have a term, right?
Say the ith term is n, n sub i--
I take 1/3 of it and add 3
to get the next term.
That's all.
This is just fancy notation
for that.
If t is the first term of the
sequence and t does not equal
0-- so this is t.
I probably didn't even
have to write this.
Ignore this if this
confuses you.
So t is the first term.
What's the next term
going to be?
It's going to be 1/3
times t plus 3.
So it's going to
be t/3 plus 3.
And they're going to say-- and
then we could keep going-- but
they just want to know, what
is the ratio of the second
term to the first term?
So what is the ratio
of this to this?
Well the ratio is t/3
plus 3, to t.
Right?
And that's the same thing
as t/3 plus 3 times 1/t.
That's the same thing as t/3
times 1/t plus 3 times 1/t.
I just distributed the 1/t.
These cancel out.
So that equals 1/3
plus 3 over t.
And that doesn't look like any
of the choices I see, so we
probably have to find a
common denominator.
So let's say the common
denominator is 3t.
Just multiply the two.
1/3 is the same thing as t over
3t, and 3/t is the same
thing as 9/3 t, right?
I just multiplied the top
and the bottom by 3.
So t plus 9/3 t.
t plus 9/3 t is choice C.
And you could even
ignore this.
Really, the hard part
isn't even this.
The hard part is actually just,
you might end up with
something like this.
And then you're like, well I
don't see that choice, and
then you have to realize, oh
I have to find a common
denominator to get to this.
The common denominator is 3t.
Well that's it.
That's a very short video.
I'll see you in the next SAT
test, or on the next SAT test.